la combinación de factores que enfrentan
y auguran un futuro bastante
pesimista sobre todo porque son seres
más este momento un millón de personas
un poquito más moción de personas en
bangladesh el coach pasar en un campo de
refugiados que están sometidos al de
casas de lona
muy muy frágil sometidos a incendios
tormentas
inundaciones y ahora en el marco de esta
ola de kobe que están siendo realmente
sabemos una población sobre todo entre
los niños y las mujeres
que les espera los rohingya en
bangladesh miles siguen en los
campamentos como usted lo dijo de
refugiados todavía sin saber dónde ir se
quedarán ahí para siempre qué pasará con
ellos
y pues por lo pronto volver a mirar no
es una opción no sólo porque las
condiciones sociales y económicas son
somos muy pobres sino porque también
este caudal militar no ha mostrado
ninguna intención de que vuelvan así que
este diría que le servirá quedarse ahí
en las condiciones en la que está y no
no no veo otra salida para mediano plazo
es decir que no podrán volver a mí al
mar en un corto plazo que han hecho las
autoridades de ese país para su regreso
y en qué momento el ejército de mianmar
rendirá cuentas por lo sucedido
hemos de saber eso hace cuatro años que
el gesto empezó su operación de limpieza
étnica para en parte sacarse de encima a
los 25 que es un pueblo que ellos
consideran que no es mi hermano también
para perjudicar entonces gobierno de
sanz sushi en su faceta internacional
los militares birmanos son
digamos nacionalistas no consideran que
son parte de su país a los
rojillos personas pues son
fundamentalistas religiosos las rojillas
son musulmanes ellos son budistas así
que me parece que nadie en una
posibilidad de una vuelta organizada y
en forma humanitaria como se debe así
que para el futuro están bangladesh y la
comunidad internacional termina que
también empieza a mirar qué pasa con eso
y es que la usted de la comunidad
internacional qué papel ha jugado
durante estos últimos cuatro años casi
nulo
y si efectivamente estamos viendo en
muchas partes del mundo que la comunidad
internacional se está mostrando poco
efectiva también porque es una etapa de
vuelta de los nacionalismos una etapa de
vuelta a los estados nacionales tienen
libertades que el siglo 20 no tenían una
vuelta donde la cuestión del liberalismo
a los derechos humanos la democracia
parece nuestra de la agenda de las
potencias emergentes y eeuu tampoco se
ha mostrado
a veces no muy interesado ya veces
tampoco cómo se ven aquí están muy bien
para hacerlo